dans le cas de la prestation mais de
façon plus générale dans ce pays on s'en
prend à tout ce qui représente l'état
des pouvoirs publics
c'est un phénomène qui s'est généralisé
depuis des années et même les pompiers
moi vous dire ça n'est qu'à une
vingtaine d'années qu à saint-astier
on s'entraînait à travailler en synergie
en étroite collaboration qui est pompier
qui quand ils interviennent dans le
monde dans le rang dans l'exercice
regarder les pompiers effectivement l'a
agressé frappé alors qu'il tentait
d'éteindre ce feu de poubelle sur lequel
ils sont encore et même au travail même
alors qu'il qu'ils défendent qui ils
sont ils sont attaqués en permanence qui
aurait imaginé il ya quelques années
c'est de cette évolution concerne
vraiment très préoccupant
merci eric d'avoir accepté notre
invitation merci beaucoup d'heures vous
êtes porte-parole des sapeurs-pompiers
vraiment des on est en admiration devant
tous tout ce que vous faites dans ce
corps de métier c'est vrai que quand on
a tous été vraiment meurtri de voir ce
qui s'est passé à samedi ce quelle a été
votre réaction à vous quand vous avez vu
ces images intolérable déjà dans un
premier temps c'est sûr que on voit les
sapeurs-pompiers donc là ce sont les
collègues militaires de la brigade des
sapeurs pompiers de paris qui sont
engagés par rapport aux manifestations
que connaît paris évidemment depuis
quelques temps on voit effectivement de
la lâcheté on voit effectivement un acte
qui est complètement
on va dire inappropriée par rapport à
l'action des secours il faut savoir
quand même que les sapeurs pompiers
aujourd'hui à raison de deux cent
cinquante trois mille agents qu'ils
soient hommes femmes sapeurs pompiers
volontaires ou professionnels
aujourd'hui ils font des interventions
pour venir protéger secourir et s'offrir
aux pulls assuré mais en aucun cas on
est là pour se faire agresser se faire
tabasser parfois j'ai envie de le dire
aussi
en aucun cas on est là pour recevoir des
coups de machettes des couteaux comme on
a pu le constater
et aujourd'hui il est fort ford
contentieux pompiers n'ont
malheureusement et vous voyez que
aujourd'hui les procédures font
qu'aujourd'hui les sapeurs pompiers sont
partis en intervention avec plus de
précaution possible donc on les voit
même avec la visière baissée c'est aussi
pour garder une certaine anonymat donc
on est dans ce respect là aussi et donc
à partir de là tout ce qu'on me le fait
qu'on espère c'est qu'on voit là c'est
des images qu'on voyait en avant de plus
en plus on voit des pompiers se faire
attaquer se faire molester
est-ce que ça devient de plus en plus
compliqué
tu es revenir ça devient de plus en
couple et plus en plus compliqué dans
tous les endroits et dans tous les
domaines aujourd'hui les sapeurs
pompiers à 3400 reprise par an sont
victimes d agressions 3410 c'est à dire
que quand vous partez en intervention
maintenant non seulement vous avez
l'angoissent 2 ce qui va de ce qui va se
passer parce que c'est un peu ce que
c'est quelqu'un de rians des brefs et en
plus là on doit se faire et c'est
surtout la compréhension on est là pour
venir au secours irait sauvés parfois
des victimes et puis d'un seul coup il
ya une rébellion général je vous
rappelle aussi que le 26 décembre donc
quelque part le lendemain des fêtes de
noël dans le vaucluse
vous avez trois sapeurs pompiers qui
venait de se faire tirer dessus par
quelqu'un vers qui ont porté secours et
vers qui on allait porter secours mais
au delà de deux de ces images qui sont
intolérables et inacceptables
il faut bien qu'on prenne en compte que
quelque part sont effectivement les
sapeurs pompiers qui parfois sont
blessés eux mêmes et qui derrière ne
peuvent plus poursuivre leur engagement
parce qu'on parle de pompiers
volontaires qui sont à 80%
l effectif global de 250 3000 sapeurs
pompiers de france et au delà de ça ça
veut dire que derrière il faut peut pas
reprendre son métier son activité
personnelle et peut pas retourner
correctement danse avec la nuit à sans
avoir ce poids sur la tête et au niveau
des pompiers professionnels c'est plus
de 1400 jours d'arrêt sur une seule
année donc c'est quand même énorme parce
que derrière il faut rétablir les
ressources mais ça va bien plus loin que
ça ça va au-delà haute idée des
véhicules les véhicules de
sapeurs-pompiers bien souvent ils sont
pris pour cible et ses véhicules dès
lors qu'ils sont abîmés touché ses seins
véhicules en moins pour porter secours
donc dès lors qu'est ce qui se passe
parce que ça aujourd'hui quand vous
appuyez sur un bouton vous appelez 112
vous savez pas ce qui se passe derrière
qu'est ce qui se passe tout simplement
qu'il faut mettre le véhicule de côté
faire appel un autre véhicule
un peu plus loin et du coup le petit
village l'état côté baisse au-dessous de
mu de secours
bien sûr quelque part quand il ya une
action comme celle ci c'est quelque part
c'est tout le système social et de
protection de sauvetage qui se fondent
alors c'est là le plus dramatique que
vous avez vu ces images
franchement c'est inadmissible a dit moi
je suis indigné mais j'ai parlé à des
pompiers ya pas très longtemps qui me
racontait une histoire qui s'est passé
il ya un mois où ils étaient ils avaient
été appelés se sont fait caillasser il
est tout simplement les mecs en fait les
appeler pour les caillasser donc ça
c'est à faire effectivement courante et
le pompier il est là pour nous sauver la
vie et à titre personnel moi j'étais
sauvé quelques mois par les pompiers
donc je peux vous dire que c'est
vraiment c'est un 10
sait on n'aurait jamais vu ce genre
d'imagés encore quelques mois je ne sais
pas ce qui se passe au niveau de la
violence et je ne comprends pas qu'on
puisse avoir la haine des pompiers c'est
pas possible
bernard est ce que vous avez un soutien
psychologique je vous dire pourquoi
parce que c'est tellement violent cet
amant inattendue c'est tellement
inacceptable
est ce que vous êtes protégé un peu
psychologiquement parce qu'entre vous
quand vous rentrez à la case et à me dit
mais qu'est-ce qui me font chier nous on
vient sauver des gens mais pourquoi on a
ça alors on a grillé valencien est le
choc
vous savez les accords conclus
aujourd'hui ce sont les soldats du feu
c'est vrai on le connaît sur des flammes
de des appartements feu sont les soldats
de la vie aussi puisque aujourd'hui 80%
du temps ce sont nos missions
aujourd'hui de porter secours aux gens
et c'est aussi les soldats du climat
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand on regarde la
tempête alex et moi j'ai affrontée par
rapport à cela a de multiples
conséquences c'est vrai que au delà de
ça on prend en compte la destra ce
psychologique de ce que l'on a pu
rencontrer je pense à mes collègues des
alpes-maritimes qui ont perdu un de
leurs collègues pendant les inondations
et les tempêtes de alex pas mal étant
prêtés avec cependant dans les
alpes-maritimes octobre dernier donc il
est clair qu'aujourd'hui il ya cette
prise de conscience écologique
mais il ya une force chez nous qui est
essentiel c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'esprit de corps ni l'esprit de la
communion qui fait qu effectivement
quand on rentre à la caserne on a cette
espèce de bulle qui nous sommes et qui
nous maintient dans notre cohésion
aidant on va dire le maintien du sens de
nos missions le sens de porter secours
l'altruisme et c'est en cela que c'est
le plus important aussi c'est de prêts
versés préserver cela pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui que ce soit les pompiers
nous aussi nos collègues de la sécurité
intérieure la police la gendarmerie
nous sommes les derniers remparts en
fait quelque part d'une nation une
stabilité et d'entretien et de liens
avec la population
6e rang parce tombe derrière vous avez
plus rien malheureusement
j'avais le cul par ce contact humain
risque de mal heureusement s'éroder eric
est ce que vous avez de plus en plus de
pompiers qui viennent vous voir et qui
vous dit j'ai envie d'arrêter plus ouais
non non c'est vrai ça c'est une heureuse
nouvelle
non c'est déjà une bonne nouvelle
quelque part il ya eu effectivement
souviens d'un collègue l'année dernière
qui a été blessé au nerf de la jambe qui
a mis du temps effectivement pour qui a
été tiré dessus qui a mis du temps
effectivement pour s'en remettre mais
revient à chaque fois dans la
confrontation il revient on va dire dans
dans le match au niveau des
interventions parce que quand vous
partez en intervention du jour au
lendemain vous savez pas forcément
pourquoi ce qu'il en est et je me
souviendrai toujours comme 2
mais à l'époque où j'étais chef de
centre à menton qui partait pour une
intervention en classique de neurologie
de victimes c'est infini que la personne
je suis allé récupérer mon collègue à la
gendarmerie pour déposer plainte parce
qu'il venait de recevoir des coups sans
aucune raison donc il ya des jeunes
encore qui veulent devenir pompier c'est
bien sûr aujourd'hui on est moins
fusante et que vous sentez cana moins
qu'avant vous salue les pompiers ça
commence dès l'âge de 13 ans il voulait
en tant que jeunes sapeurs pompiers
on leur apprend un petit peu l'éducation
les valeurs républicaines on leur
apprend aussi le sens de l'altruisme et
aujourd'hui on était passé à quelques
années de 30000 et aujourd'hui on est à
35 milles et on a de plus en plus de
demandes qu'on a du mal à absorber et
donc ça veut dire qu'il ya une recherche
de code il ya une recherche quelque part
on va dire d'un certain harry tda
certains cadrages qui vont permettre au
fur et à mesure on l'espère de pouvoir
un moment donné venir à bout de ce genre
de choses là et je n'en rajoute et aussi
c'est que nos autorités d'état
travaillent aussi puisqu'un plan de de
lutte contre les agressions visés par
les chercheurs concluent bien développé
des ou 2020 avec le ministère de
l'intérieur et charles da manha donc ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya des
actions qui seront menées mais
croyez-moi c'est délicat pour un pompier
aujourd'hui d'expliquer tu vas partir en
intervention tu vas mettre un gilet par
l'âme il faut rajouter des filtres de
protection sur sur les vitres des
ambulances donc aujourd'hui ce genre de
choses là il faut prendre en compte
malheureusement on est toujours
confronté à ce genre de situation et
nous derrière les sapeurs pompiers on
essaie de maintenir ce cadre et veillez
toujours mais ça ça concerne aujourd'hui
tout le territoire quel message vous
auriez à faire passer à ceux qui qui
vous voilà qui qui s'en prennent à vous
ça ne s'est pas qu'un jour ils auront
besoin de vous mais bien sûr c'est une
peur bleue à nous comme leurs proches
leur maman avant que l'enfant peut avoir
besoin de nous bien sûr le discernement
c'est extrêmement important on comprend
qu'à un moment donné on subit une
tension sociale
si on allait aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya
une tension sociale est long aujourd'hui
on se présente et quelque part on est
représentant de l'état aussi quelque
part que représentant les collectivités
territoriales bien entendu aussi donc à
partir de là nous sommes vulnérables
mais c'est à nos jours les gens qui qui
qui s'en prennent aux pompiers faut bien
viser compreniez que peut-être votre
maman demain et oui alors a besoin des
pompiers votre grand-mère votre petit
frère votre frère et c'est vrai que ça
c'est qu'on aimerait aussi c'est de voir
des mouvements autour des gens qui
retiennent les personnes c'est ça ouais
maintenant aujourd'hui on est tellement
capter farm l'image par le machin que du
coup on en oublie le sens non mais
attends je suis en train de filmer un
pompey qui se fait tabasser
moi je le retire pas et si on vient
aider les pompiers de cette manière là
c'est déjà quelque part des pompiers -
bc des images moins virulente vous
dernier que les sanctions faites plus
fortes
alors les sanctions le son on va dire
déjà en titre d'exemple mais on n'en
parle pas assez c'est vrai qu'on parle
certes agression et mercy était encore
pour une somme pour cet accueil ce soir
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui quand un
sapeur pompier est agressé on porte
aujourd'hui déclaration les sanctions
l'économie oui les prisons ferme qui
sont quand même maintenant dernièrement
au bout de six jours parce qu'un sapeur
pompier a été agressé et qui portait
grâce à lui la caméra piétons qui était
une avancée aussi en terme de deux
réformes au niveau de la protection des
sapeurs pompiers derrière six jours
après avoir détecté la personne il a
pris six mois de prison ferme
parfois ça va bien au delà dernièrement
ça a été aussi trois ans pour une
personne qui a porté atteinte
directement sapeurs pompiers je vous
rappelle quand même que notre collègue
de la brigade et sa collègue militaires
de la brigade des sapeurs-pompiers de
paris en 2018 geoffroy henry et même
décédés par une personne alors qu'il
venait tout simplement faire un secours
à victimes classique qu'eric donc est ce
que vous feriez pompiers aujourd'hui
bien sûr d'être 7 euros vous êtes fier
détrompez vous êtes vous aujourd'hui non
seulement je suis fier mais je citerai
ce que tout le monde puisse venir
profiter et regarder un petit peu ce que
c'est la notion de l'engagement mais
aujourd'hui on constate au quotidien
puisque même les sapeurs pompiers dans
différents départements que ce soit le
gard ou d'autres biens d'autres bien
entendu vont à l'intérieur des écoles
pour expliquer ce que c'est le métier
l'activité de sapeur-pompier parce qu'on
peut rentrer pompiers volontaires sans
faire pour autant son métier mais
simplement par l'engagement parce que
j'ai dû tendre disponible et que je peux
devenir pompier volontaire